foreign whoa
well who are they Jurassic Park
oh no I think I found out what they're
hiding down oh no
yes he's a fortress I love it oh no we
know him oh I love it oh the Jedi who
helped Ahsoka find her lightsaber I love
this I love this
put Leia in the honeycomb put legs in
there
oh no those okay don't know who they are
this is
oh I wonder is that a rokin's wife you
think
all right I hope it's everybody I hope
it's everybody
[Music]
no time okay stop looking it's not a
museum start going run run run run run
run
oh my God
this is oh
stop stop get out of there it's gonna be
you
why what's happened oh my God oh my God
welcome back to New rockstars Obi-Wan
Kenobi episode 4 shows us just how easy
it is apparently to break out of an
impenetrable Imperial Fortress all you
gotta do is just a bit of light jogging
you know hopping it into an imperial
officer's terminal during his bathroom
break and then kill him as quietly as
you can in an otherwise silent room then
tuck a 10 year old in your trench coat
and just walk past dozens of
Stormtroopers and then stuff four people
in the back of the cockpit of a t-47 a
bit of a cakewalk I gotta say but you
know what it's okay this is all because
Reba wanted him to escape so now it is
on us to break down and identify all
those dead Jedi because you could have
given us a name or two
yeah this is Wookie leaks it's our after
show for Obi-Wan Kenobi on Disney plus
I'm Eric Voss my Easter egg breakdown
for this episode is coming tomorrow
Tommy bechtold could not join us this
week he's got some very important
matters to attend to but filling in to
chat about episode four right now is
Jessica Clemens welcome Jessica
two things two things two things really
quick number one how are we gonna just
uh like underplay that Kenobi just did
the two kids in a trench coat walk out
of the building with baby Leia are we
gonna act like that didn't just happen
and two yeah why didn't they put little
like plaques under each Jedi they killed
they could have put like a little name
and like date they took them just like
on award I've read that as an unmarked
grave they don't respect them that much
that they're just gonna shove them in
this weird Amber uh and not even not
even mark their names because their
names are no longer important you know
like each of their lightsabers I assume
are the ones on that red shelf in the uh
inquisitors meeting room so that I like
how like on that shelf it's also some
domed young lean helmets but they kept
the helmet on the one kid it's like a
kid who like you know he has his bike
helmet on still oh I don't use that as
the analogy that's where worse that's
worse
but they did let him they do respect the
dead because they get they let him have
his helmet they took all the other
helmets but they let him or maybe they
shot out the back of his head and they
don't want that to be seen that's true
it can be too gory of about yeah there's
probably a lot of messed up bodies that
didn't make it into this it's only the
ones that were in that's right that guy
because I was thinking like would you
Costa new be up there I don't know there
was a you know she was on like a a
shuttle with Vader in that comic when
Vader let her die so her body might be
beyond recognition uh Mace Windu who
knows what things he hit on the way down
on that fall from the this from the
Chancellor's quarters also Mace Windu
doesn't deserve to be in the inquisitors
like uh like on that I feel like he
deserves to be somewhere else he's
higher up he's really cool that his body
would probably be somewhere else on
display I would think so yeah unless or
being used in some other weird way
because we know the grand Inquisitor use
luminar and bullies corpse in some
pretty messed up ways and Rebels uh or
maybe mazewood is still alive there's a
lot of different ways to read it uh but
I think you do bring up an important
question of uh the Scooby-Doo tactics
used to sneak out Leia from The Fortress
we're far too effective in this episode
so goofy this show no one's recognizing
how silly this show is he threw spice on
the ground to get away from flea like
the the chase scene in the forest and
now this I love it don't get me wrong
but I was like these are all like
Scooby-Doo tactics
be I think we also have to recognize
that Star Wars historically is a
franchise there's a lot of goof Town
stuff in it I was surprised that he
didn't put on some Stormtrooper gear to
sneak around
so many Star Wars movies people dressing
up as Imperials happen in this episode
technically why did they not do it why
did they not do it I thought he was I
was like take the costume take the soup
take the soup like you did before
because he didn't need to it was just he
just luckily you're gonna be on uh on a
floor that was only monitored by just
Imperial probe droids just kind of
floating around it's happened to turn
their heads in the other way so he could
kind of just kind of quietly jog past
them hey it works right we get
criticized if it worked
true true okay let's quickly recap what
happened so in this episode
Tyler takes Kenobi to jabeen it takes
him straight to the back to Bath an
incredible opening Montage here I love
the inner cutting but with the breathing
evader playing over Obi-Wan and the back
to back we cut to uh Vader sensing
Obi-Wan it's like whenever these two
take a back to Bath their
consciousnesses can sense each other and
I loved how they kind of set this up
with the book of bow pet right like when
you're in a back to bat your mind goes
places that's like a sensory deprivation
tank and it kind of makes them uh detach
from their physical body in a weird way
and More in touch with uh the force and
their midterians and now it's kind of
like they feel each other in this bath
it's like they're taking a bath together
it's like two twins you know when they
their parents put them in the tub in
that creepy picture that a lot of
parents take of siblings when they're
young it's like that's what's happening
to the brothers here they're back in the
bath and they can feel each other and I
love this song yes
to me this was like the high water mark
of the episode how about you Jessica
this was like this is great and it's
maybe because like we're seeing hate it
like the series promised us Hayden and a
lot of Vader in this series is being
done with the Reese feature technology
reproducing James Earl Jones voice and
then a stand-in for the actor who plays
Vader who's doing a pretty great job I
don't want to knock anything he's doing
I just I like more Anakin on the show I
like more Hayden yeah I was more
confused at whether or not it was a
montage back and forth of um Obi-Wan
being able to like feel or sense that
like that's the same thing Anakin went
through or if it was just
um for the audience to see like oh see
how it's kind of mimicking each other
they're now becoming like the same I
didn't know which one it was I didn't
know if it was like Obi-Wan could feel
it or not yeah but yeah we couldn't
interpret it either way for sure yeah I
just think that there was a shot of
Vader in the tank deliberately like
turning his head upward as if he was
looking at someone as if you sense
okay and then I think that also fed to
Obi-Wan as saying no to that bad cutting
that bath short as I would do yeah he
did my parents have lost yeah I'm like
I'm clean yeah good but
um I'm done I think part of it was like
there's no time we gotta get to Leia I
think another part of it was yeah the
longer I'm in this tank the more Vader
can sense where I am and how I'm feeling
and that freaks me I think it's both I
think it's that one a little bit more
though like I think he still fears
Anakin and Vader clearly because he's
like I let this person die this was we
were brothers Anakin like I think he's
just like this really hurts me like I
need to save Leia but this is like a
triggering traumatizing moment for me
and I do not want to relive this yes
exploring that pain has been I think uh
one of my favorite things my favorite
series it's my favorite part it's my
it's unfortunate that it's my favorite
part but it gives so much depth to the
storyline it makes me actually like I
mean I always humanized Obi-Wan Kenobi
regardless but the seeing that scene was
the part where I was like oh my God this
he's going through a lot of Trials like
he's going through a lot right now he
might be the strongest Jedi but not
right now not right now not right now on
jabeen we meet the others who are
helping the refugees the Jedi refugees
on the path this includes broken O'Shea
Jackson Jr's character wasn't Quinlan
boss swinging a Miss for me on that one
uh Sully that's my erskine's character
and we meet Wade Ryder McLaughlin who
later this dude gets a Boston link
moment of silence despite us hardly
getting to know the guy I was like
really for Wade like I get it it's sad
that he's dead but like we're gonna spin
a solid 60 seconds just remembering Wade
uh at the end of this episode uh I had
no connection to him I had no feel or
attachment to Wade and I felt bad like I
forgot that he was there to be honest
with you I was like that one guy who had
something to say about Nur in the
Fortress and then Maya Erskine had to go
wait and I'm like okay I guess his name
is Wade anyway
um but I didn't know his name uh poor
guy they put they've had him smile right
before that bomb hit him he's like I did
it
I did it
uh so uh Rogan reveals that his wife was
force sensitive but the inquisitors took
her and he's like okay I'll actually
help you and then tala uses her Imperial
credentials to sneak them onto the
Fortress and quasitorious on ner and
Tyler was able to talk her way right in
while Obi-Wan uses a rebreather to pull
a cow cast his stroke into the lower
levels of the base where he then manages
a pretty easy stroll through the
Fortress undetected while reeva tells
Leia that Ben is dead and tries to force
Leia to tell her what she knows about
the path but Leia is no snitch so Riva
sets up a torture session for a child
thank God we don't get there uh because
Obi-Wan uh finds what tala had said was
being hidden on this Fortress a Jedi
tomb filled with dozens of Jedi some
familiar faces some new faces we'll run
through the ones we were able to
identify in just a moment thankfully
Obi-Wan has been too long in that tomb
uh because that torture session was like
it was like movie timing like
[Music]
we have not moved the needle forward at
all in the scene yet we are cutting back
to them again tala is able to distract
Riva it's not even Obi-Wan who gets to
them first like tala is able to
intervene first by telling Riva that the
path leads to a different planet pull in
a dental moment but uh while Obi-Wan's
able to free Leia he gets into a
shootout that results in a blaster
cracking the glass you would think that
either they would build the glass to be
Blaster resistant or maybe be a bit more
careful about thank you seems Seems like
a stupid idea seems like the dumbest
thing who was the architect who built
this ship because you if a gun's laser
could penetrate it why would you ever
have a bunch of people with these gun
lasers on a ship that makes
hey look I I get the set piece I like
that water broke in because it gives us
some nice parallels to Jedi Fallen order
when Vader was able to hold back the
gushing water I thought that all looked
really cool
um but I just think practically it'd be
one thing for the purchasing Chords it's
notorious to be mostly underwater
because you know they were kicked off of
a Coruscant when they had a former
training camp called The Works and now
they're trying to be a bit more off the
grid a lot of people around the Galaxy
don't really know that the inquisitors
exist they're kind of like a
the emperor has like a a goon squad who
goes around hunting wait so not
everybody knows that they I think at
this point word's gotten out there
because you know they're walking around
my tattooing saying the Jedi code is
like an itch but like
I think people like bail or Ghana and
other Senators man mothma are like hey
you're not still running those those
Hunters are you oh no there
maybe they might be on there
um but I think the whole point of them
being on nurse that they're closer to
Mustafar and they're a bit more off the
grid so uh but this this Fortress still
juts out of the water in a very phallic
fashion you would think they could have
just built most of it underwater to
avoid detection
no no no no you don't understand this
looks nicer this way it looks it looks
more menacing this way we need an evil
Fortress the visual is great and I think
all of this is being driven by the art
and the visuals and I'm not complaining
about that I'm saying practically it
doesn't make a whole lot of
to build nervous whatever I love it but
that's also that keeps it real that
keeps it real because there's a lot of
architecture that you're like this
actually is not working at all it
doesn't do anything but it does look
very nice so I like that it's keeping us
on our like this is a real thing this is
what it would look like it was great
idea horrible execution and I think we
should also acknowledge this is Star
Wars they have a big moon size battle
stage
100. torpedo to go through and blow the
whole thing up uh like there's all kinds
of impracticalities it's just in the
name of well it looks really cool and
that's why I like Star Wars so no
complaints
um so they're able to escape the main
level by hiding Leia in Obi-Wan's trench
coat and I gotta say when we first
walked into this uh Fortress there were
some of these Imperial officers and
trench coats and I was thinking like I
don't remember seeing them in trench
coats that's a cool new design flourish
I guess the uh the Misty weather of ner
requires a bit more outerwear cool they
really just gave some of them trench
coats to set up Obi-Wan to sneak Leia
out in one of them which I think is just
hilarious
am I allowed to post about this on
Twitter now am I alone I was gonna post
an image of this and be like this is
this is insane you guys this happened
and it worked and it worked for a good
solid minute I love that Riva was the
only one that was like there is an old
man in a child
related species in a trench coat uh two
daddy legs two little girl legs just
kind of skittering beside him in a real
lumpy trench coat silhouette Yes No
One's Gonna say anything
Riva Riva is the voice of reason and I
love it Reba I she's yeah she's a
villain but her character is so good and
the fact that no one else not like she
had to come out and be like you guys are
all idiots look at that weird thing
they're just like walking limping
also if tala dies I believe this is
working
yeah oh my God this is working uh if
Tyler dies I'm gonna be very upset but
that's a that's a that's another story
because stala's done too much work this
season so far in two episodes yeah too
much work today she's done a lot of
heavy lifting absolutely yes so Sully
and weight show up in a couple t-47s you
remember these these were The Empire
Strikes Back hothspeeders that you know
uh tripped up the the at-ats the atats
um but these are two seaters so it's
amazing that Tyler and Obi-Wan and lit
now I'm not surprised Leia can cram in
there she's a little mop it but Obi-Wan
and tala cram it in into a seat that's
meant for one person in the back of uh
Sully's t-47 pretty pretty impressive uh
um Tetris work getting them in there but
uh Riva uh man Riva doesn't let Wade get
away poor Wayne R.I.P Wade never forget
Wade no he was still gonna get a
10-minute Memorial uh funeral scene for
Wade next episode that's what I'm
assuming will happen I hope not
um I said I hope not this is the villain
in me talking but also Maya ashgren's
character was like come on leave it
alone and he was still shooting right
um at Riva so I think Riva had that
chance to like really throw something at
him which also was what what did she
throw what was it that she like threw at
him was it a bomb Oh a um a a box bomb I
don't know yeah that's what I thought I
was like I thought it was a cinder block
and I was like how did a cinder block do
that
I don't know I think they just got some
loose bombs stacked up yeah
understandable I'm in case anyone trips
you know the whole thing goes up I'm
telling you the this place is very
practically designed there's a reason
for those just sitting there I'm sorry
should never ask should have never asked
should have assumed should have assumed
that's on me I don't know everything on
that deck is a weapon I just assumed and
everything is so that I'm never gonna
get over that trench coat ever in my
life I might get it tattooed on me I
might get a tattooed on me it is so
funny and so perfect I mean and I think
we just gave uh London Fog a new
advertising campaign if you have a name
to sneak out to Childs from an imperial
Fortress
yes yes
thank you thank you oh so uh but you
know as much as we want to joke about
this it seems like Riva did this on
purpose at least Riva did because she
reveals she left a Tracker with Leia her
her little Droid Lola your Droid lighten
up red recording everything and while
Leia is not a snitch
Lola might be a snitch we're gonna find
out
um but we promised it at the top we're
gonna break down everything we know
about every single one of those entombed
Jedi uh that we can uh determine But be
sure to check out new rockstarsmerch.com
to grab our latest Obsession Empire's
Most Wanted shirt inspired by the
Obi-Wan Kenobi series like all of our
latest Obsession shirts it's a limited
edition release and once the shirt's
gone it's gone forever unlike the grand
Inquisitor we think he's coming back and
when he purchased this latest Obsession
shirt you unlock the ability to get a
custom shout out that will appear right
here on Wikileaks at the bottom of the
screen so let's review what some people
are saying Dylan says How likely is it
that we'll get some Clone Wars era
flashbacks only three episodes left well
two episodes left as of this episode but
yeah I think at this point not that
likely I'm not gonna I'm not gonna build
up my expectations too much for this
show uh but I think if it means we get
to see Hayden Christensen on screen
great uh I would love to see that I
think realistically the Clone Wars era
flashbacks are going to be in Andor
they're going to be in Ahsoka I don't
know if this uh this series is time for
that
Trenton says do you guys think we'll see
Hayden Christensen in Ahsoka as well
um I think so way better I I said we
better I think yeah I think that would
be a great place for a clone war is
there a flashback with the with Sky guy
and Snips uh is that something you'd
like to see Jess yes
yeah also yeah they they just better she
he trained her he trained her there
better be flashbacks yeah there better
be and then Riley says Ewoks are the
real heroes well Riley you can burn in
hell no I'm just kidding that's great a
guy
what did Ewoks do to you can I nothing I
love the Ewoks I I love all of them and
I love you Riley you're right they are
the real heroes they're wonderful little
things who did nothing but but save the
Battle of endors so we have to show them
some respect but um but Jessica what's
the question we're asking after this
episode of Obi-Wan Kenobi I think the
question the hot take is who were the
Jedi corpses in the Tomb yeah who were
the honeycombed yeah I love it uh they
were casting this honeycomb Amber as
opposed to Carbonite which is
interesting it's like they want us to be
able to see them and learn from their uh
from their form their clothing their
appearance their the last look on their
face uh is their expression but you
don't really see much about what they're
I think these are just trophies like
animals heads on walls like it's just
like walk down this long hallway long
this long Corridor tour to a a torture
booth and look at all the other people
we tortured and murdered well I think
there may be a practical purpose as well
because we know from Rebels season 1
episode 5 the grand Inquisitor uses the
mummified corpse of luminar unduly to
lure and Canaan nezer in a trap and I
think that might be the plan for each of
these Jedi if you put them in carbonite
I don't think that uh trap would work as
well that that trick but in this case
they're still they're not fully in
carbonite they're in this other
suspended form and I think that would
allow the grand Inquisitor Invader to
use the their Essence their spiritual
Force Essence to make other Jedi to
think that they're still alive that's my
theory for why they're they're in this
amber color makes sense so
um now from my account looking at this
quarter it looked like there was like 48
cells because it looked like there were
eight on each side of the lower level
and then that would give us 16 on the
lower level and then up top there were
similar Cubbies above them and it looked
like there were 16 on top there may be
others stacked behind them but I think
there's around like 48 there's a there's
a couple dozen at least of these
um but we only see a handful of them so
the first one we get a close-up is this
goat-like looking species it's called
akosian and this is Terra sunube uh
that's uh a guy who's familiar to
Watchers of the Clone Wars and it's
pretty heartbreaking because he was an
elderly Jedi Master whom Ahsoka met in
the Jedi Temple archives introduced to
her by Jocasta new this guy marshaled a
Jedi outpost on Dara and his uh in his
past he was a former member of the Jedi
High Council he led a young lean Clan uh
and yeah in that episode he helped a
young Ahsoka Tano recover her lightsaber
this guy's so sweet he carried a white
lightsaber a silver colored lightsaber
that he kept in a cane it just sucks to
see him dead because he was only a nice
guy like he used to be on the Jedi High
Council and he's like no not for me I'm
just gonna look after the Younglings he
didn't even have the Sass that Jocasta
new did he was just a nice old grandpa
and they killed him they killed him well
and I'm wondering if it sucks to suck
Grandpa
I'm wondering if like he might have
helped that Wookie Jedi gungy Escape
because we saw Genji in the bad batch
season 2 trailer and uh I feel like I
feel like a Tara might have helped out
with that that's my hope at least
um but really the first ones you can see
in the sequence are actually in a wide
shot from the far end of the corridor on
the right is an angry male and this
could be one of two people it might be
Jedi Master Coleman cassaj who sat on
the Jedi Council during the events of
Revenge of the Sith he appeared in a
number of Clone Wars Episodes it might
also be another angry Jedi Pablo Jill
who appears during attack of the Clones
but Coleman cassaj served at least uh or
he survived the initial wave of The
Purge during Order 66 because his name
appeared on a list of surviving Jedi
still hunted by the inquisitors back in
the 2017 Charles Soul Darth Vader Comics
but we should note that list also
includes Quinlan boss and if you slide
on over the left of that wide shot there
is a male Jedi with great hair and I
really really really does look like
Quinlan boss the only difference is you
don't see the yellow face paint stripe
across his face but he is in that amber
colored lights that might just mask it
it would be super surprising to seek
when boss be revealed this way with no
close-up reaction by Obi-Wan right after
Obi-Wan just learned Quinlan Voss has
been helping along with the path uh and
read that meaningful quote from Quinlan
I think tala would have known if Quinlan
was captured
um I think Quinlan wouldn't have been
mentioned last episode if he was just
going to be among the case here so I'm
thinking that this guy is not Quinlan
just the one who looks like him
um now uh the two there are two other
Jedi visible in that shot beside Coleman
corsage there is a hooded female with a
messenger bag and then beside the one
who looks like winland there's a Jetta
with an interesting shaped head or
headpiece
um but then as Obi-Wan walks past these
cells there's a few new faces uh there's
one with an odd Square shaped headpiece
another one with thick padded armor and
then a close-up of a woman's face in
shock and then a woman wearing a poncho
and a necklace and I believe that one of
these two women might be roken's wife uh
because they both got significant
close-ups and they weren't wearing
particularly Jedi robes they were
wearing just more commoner clothes do
you think he's gonna he's gonna somehow
see it I think he's either I think he's
gonna be notified about this like I
think Obi-Wan when he gets back to to
him he might have a picture of his wife
and then Obi-Wan's like oh I hate to
break it to you but oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah 100
people flashback to it that's my
thinking but uh we were left with this
young lean kid
um and this is actually someone we have
seen before uh because in the credits of
this episode he's credited as the actors
the twin brothers Jonathan ho and Oliver
ho who are also credited as playing one
of the young leads in the order 66
flashback in episode one in the prologue
so this is one of those kids and they
they cast him in Amber right away so
that tells us that right the night or
the week of Order 66 they already
started casting these uh these Jedi
corpses in this Amber stuff so this was
something that they had prepared that
they're like maybe we can use their
corpses to capture the rest of them
right away put them on Ice put them on
ice and if Reba was one of those kids to
walk past that every day the anger the
the what is deep down boiling in her who
is she fighting against the inhumanity
of her being able to pass by that to see
uh like one of her classmates still just
as young as he was
on that night when she broke off so it's
just really messed up obviously uh as
Obi-Wan leases quarter there's actually
another sighting a bald dark-skinned man
who might be Mace Windu no but again I
think someone that significant Obi-Wan
would have given a double take to we
would have gotten a close-up of them uh
also the big uh Smoking Gun there he has
his right hand clearly visible and and
Anakin Skywalker sliced off Mace Windu's
right arm maybe he got a new one in the
time between me he just arrived and then
also got captured I don't know that's
just a lot of steps I don't think this
is Mace Windu
um now who else might be among these
there's a good chance that among these
of course is luminar unduly based off of
how uh the grand Inquisitor used her
corpse similarly and Rebels so we didn't
see her here but she might be somewhere
in the stacks
um and there's plenty of other Jedi who
had been hunted by inquisitors Invader
and Clone Troopers who might be here as
well like it's implied that all of them
whose bodies that they could recover are
here in this in this room so that would
include plokun Chiari Mundi Ayla Sakura
deepavalaba syndrawling maybe jaro te
Paul from Jedi Fallen order they all
could be here but I want to ask you
let's let's dig into this do you think
Mace Windu is among these if not no
where do you think basically do it or
where is his body I don't think he I
don't think he is I don't think he is
and I agree with what you said I don't
think he would be put in something like
that I think he'd be somewhere else he's
a high up he's a high up he's a high up
boy so I don't think he would be I mean
no I don't think he'd be there I think
he'd be somewhere else but also if Mace
Windu was alive I would also ride that
train uh we all love Mace Windu so
clearly I would love for him to come
back but yeah I think he's also dead I'm
I'm just on that train because that like
I think is uh
I think there's just a great opportunity
there for Samuel L Jackson to come back
in a cannon and I think there's a great
story there and all I really want is
just like opportunities for stories to
to find their path so 100 I think this
is 100 so we have a couple more
questions we want to dig into this
episode obviously uh we want to thank G
fuel for sponsoring this episode if
you're looking for a way to add a little
more energy to your day check out what
Jessica's got she's got some cheese it's
a sugar-free energy drink made from
natural ingredients it's used by UFC
fighters and Esports athletes and
bodybuilders and skateboarders YouTube
Stars fitness models even NFL players
there are over 20 unique and delicious
flavors to choose from and while G fuel
does contain caffeine they do offer a
caffeine-free g-fuel hydration formula
so if you are new to G fuel or already a
fan of the product you can click the
link in our description below to get 10
off your G fuel order while supporting
our Channel that's 10 off your order of
G fuel while using our Link in the
description okay Jess back to this
episode I want to ask you okay where do
you think the path ultimately leads I
don't know so it's where everyone is
safe right it's where all the Jedis can
kind of run away where the hell would
they be hiding it's not what what if
it's Tatooine no it's not Tatooine
because they were over there and it's
not moves too far
uh where else would it be I mean I I
think it's like that furnace that all
all of Andy's toys almost fell into in
Toy Story three that they just have an
assembly line and they throw the Jedi in
there like trust me this is better this
is better than what the inquist it's
better than being cast in that weird
honeycomb so you're welcome but no I I'm
wondering if like
they might just be spread out everywhere
like in a witness protection kind of
thing but I honestly think they're more
they're safer in their own kind of
colony you know because like they that's
what uh broken said this episode you can
try all you want to just blend in if
you're a Jedi but they're gonna find you
they have their you know you have Force
sensitivity they have holocrons or
whatever they're gonna be able to track
you down so I think it's better if like
they're put in some other kind of colony
where they can be defended and maybe
have some like uh reverse Force
sensitivity uh beams that they can fire
out like a little Shield to like so like
Rick and Morty like counter out their
brain leaves yeah yeah right like yeah
the neutralizer Jedi signal
um uh so I'm wondering if it could be uh
places like crate because it seems like
they're using mining systems to move
them around and then crate in The Last
Jedi was abandoned uh and had some kind
of significance to it I'm wondering also
maybe python that we saw in uh in the
Mandalorian season two that was where
there was some old Jedi Ruins that had
that um altar where Luke Skywalker was
able to track that Beacon so that might
be part of the path as well
um I think eventually most of the Jedi
are just gonna be dead or wiped out yeah
but I think positive kids are always
going to be a thing they occur naturally
um I think the place of mandalorians
still looked too nice for it to be the
place that they attack
um if it's the same place I'm thinking
we're thinking about the place where
maybe I'm getting book of book a Boba
Fett in Mandalorian season two are blur
to me um
is it it's not where um kylo Ren was
exploded everything right
um no yeah kylo Ren that wasn't exploded
so we don't know uh that was a new
planet that has still not been named
right so that was in the book of Boba
Fett and we don't even know if that was
the same planet where kylo wrecked it as
a kid yeah it was implied to have been
that same Jedi school right that was
implied to have been the same one it
just was never named either in the the
Prelude comics of kylo's kylo Ren's
backstory or in the book above that
episode five and six okay
okay then ignore me then ignore me I go
with whatever you said yeah I mean I
think that planet was just located uh
located by Luke later on in the timeline
after the Galactic Civil War is Over
um I think there was uh these other
spots on the path that uh that you know
each Jedi was kind of Lily padding among
uh or for sensitive person until
eventually they were found or you know
outed uh but the path the path isn't
going to be like new Asgard where it's
like the path is the people not the city
it's not going to be that that code is a
people not a win is the I don't want it
to be like they get there and they're
like where are they and it's like it's
just who we are I'd be like no it needs
to be a physical place where they're all
hiding
well my theory uh and this still may be
the case but it's probably a reach uh is
that at least for some of these
younglings that the path could
ultimately lead to the watch to the
Mandalorian watch the formerly the death
watch uh that that could be and then
they try to Stamp Out Your Force
sensitivity with this new Mandalorian
dogma of never showing your face and
believing in these other things in your
Signet and your clan uh and and bescar's
sacred qualities uh but that secretly
some of these young leans in the watch
uh did have some Force sensitivity uh
nested inside of them but the the reason
I love that
theory it's just also it says more
characters who didn't need to be Jedi
are now Jedi and I'm not crazy about
that that's fine there's a lot of eyes
there's a ton of Jedi's Josh shaft he's
a Jedi
that was the younger one that was the
younger one what Danny yeah Danny's a
Jedi
ately
whatever the other one the other one is
a anyone can be a Jedi that's true that
is true
um so um but I think it ultimately leads
somewhere uh it might just lead to some
new planet that we didn't know of in
Star Wars Canon previously that tends to
be what they're doing a lot like rather
than bring in something familiar that
has a lot of importance they want
something to have a lot of importance
something new a new name a new proper
noun
um a question I think we should talk
about assuming Leia you know based off
of Star Wars history she's going to
reunite with her parents to organs bail
or gone is still a senator
um is he going to demand the end of The
Inquisitor program because now he's
knows like if Leia gets back to at some
point he's gonna know that The
Inquisitor the third sister took her or
is this gonna Force Vader and Palpatine
to move the inquisitors even more
underground like we know the inquisitors
are still around in rebels of course but
are they still gonna have as uh the
status the reputation that they had or
the they currently have on this show
like what's going to be the political
Fallout from this I guess is what I'm
wondering is there a world
where bail Organa uh
uh is okay still with I don't know he
loves Leia so much that I don't think he
would be okay with them regard after
knowing this maybe we end the season
with thinking not us clearly because we
know but like the inquisitors are all
dead something happened like a huge
battle happens and Vader's like they all
died they all died fighting Obi-Wan
Kenobi for your daughter so Bale's like
there's no use to even talk about them
they don't exist anymore but they
clearly do I feel like it's a goofy
justification but the the Star Wars is
silly it's it's Camp so I think they
could still go with that justification
of like we think they're all gone but
they're not well I think uh you're on to
something a little depressing about this
that uh bail might let it slide because
if he races a stink about it then like
he's like well then why was my daughter
taken what is their connection what is
my connection to Obi-Wan Kenobi it risks
her daughter for there to be a whole
Senate investigation about this but he's
got to play it just right because if he
doesn't complain at all that's also
going to raise some red flags with
Palpatine like his Palpatine would
wonder well then why didn't bail Organa
raise his stink what is he hiding right
now so he's got he's got this awkward a
path to walk where he has to be pissed
off but he can't like push it so far
that everyone's gonna raise an
investigation of who Leia is and why
Leia is with the organs and I think
that's the reason we also get that scene
at the beginning with the family member
where they're trying to approach a dark
topic and the cousin or whatever is like
no I'm here to just party I'm not here
to talk about like what's happening with
slaves like deep down in the bowels so I
think it's clear that like he can't he's
trying so hard to be good but he's a
senator like he can't there's a lot of
things that are just people aren't going
to vote to be good so yeah I think I
think the most uh good Baylor ground is
trying to do like they had that line in
episode one and then Obi-Wan mentioned
him last episode there's there's only so
much political good that can be done
he's really just doing that to
try to address things like slavery in
the outer rim he's trying to uh but
really just trying to keep up a front
because you know of course he's working
with Monmouth might have fun Jedi or not
Jedi but uh Rebel efforts so uh I think
really that's a practical good he's
doing but uh I think it's interesting I
think this series is going to end with a
little hint of Leia uh spark of
rebellion in Leia she's going to want to
start helping I like it's different in
uh canonical literature I believe Leia
finds out Breya and
and Organa or bail are involved in like
Jedi operation Jedi rebel operations
later in a different Mission when she's
like a teenager because she's like 16
years old and then she starts helping
out but uh I wonder if like they might
hint at this point where they leave Leia
with a bit of Suspicion of what her
dad's really involved with I think so I
think so I think we're planning it we're
planning it for sure yeah I love also
that line where she was like let me call
my dad if we're on the same team right
and Revo was like look here
you know what
I hate you I'm squaring up with a
six-year-old right now and I hate you
yeah I love it um overall I'm still
really enjoying the show uh I love any
kind of connection we can get between
Ewan McGregor and Hayden Christensen uh
I actually like the the Leia actress I
know she's getting some heat but I I
love her she's great I think she's
really fun could you do that at 10 could
you guys do that at seven no I couldn't
open my mouth when I was 10. I was a
little shy I didn't know how to read
well that was a problem Jesse
no uh but I think this was the episode
where I struggled I think the most to uh
I I still enjoyed everything I was
looking at it was just like the logic
The Fortress inquisitories is such a
cool location and it it still looked
really cool it's just practically it
made it feel kind of stupid uh I loved
it still I I but I think I'm just like
this is this is perfect this is silly
and also great I love it it was fun I
like this this might be my favorite
episode wow and wow I'm not gonna say
I'm not gonna say that it was the trench
coat that stole it for me
I think it's the dead Jedi it's the it's
the tomb it's the tomb of those Jedis
I loved it but here's what I wanted and
this is just like the Jedi uh Star Wars
nerd in me like I wanted more I wanted
more I felt like they were playing a
little safe they could have shown us a a
more of a VIP in that tank you know
there's people you could have put a plug
in there you could have put it you could
have put Chiari Mundi and that would
have been a bit creepier maybe they're
like Well we'd have to credit the actor
but whatever they're crediting James
Earl Jones by using a robot to talk for
us they are yeah they're they're
definitely walking on like eggshells
they're they're a little too cautious I
think which is understandable Star Wars
fans we know
you will kill us if we get something
wrong so I feel like riding that was
probably kind of hard because they were
like they even said in an interview that
it was just like they didn't know like
canonically whether or not
um Obi-Wan new evader was uh dead or
Anakin so it's like they it takes a lot
of steps it takes a lot of steps it
takes a lot of knowledge so the writers
don't but they have like people from
lucasfilm who are Consulting to kind of
keep them on yeah that's true like Pablo
Hidalgo is his way into there uh they're
all kind of helping out they all get
help from like Dave filoni and John
Favreau uh to to make this all line up
it's just like compared to like the big
swings that the Mandalorian was taking
with things like Kroger's surviving
Order 66 you know it's like a Roku
exists like it felt like there were
weird big swings the Mandalorian we
learned so much more about the
Mandalorian culture suddenly there's a
cult of animals who never take off their
helmets like all this John big swings
it's because it's John Favreau John
Favreau was like I'm gonna do whatever I
wanna do he was like you guys can't tell
me to stop like but I am kind of
irritated that like Kenobi Obi-Wan
Kenobi couldn't break the rules like
Mandalorian yeah I feel like it should
it's Obi-Wan Kenobi and like as long as
you have the lucasfilmo team all kind of
in there saying like well we can't go
this far uh and I know the counter
argument is that well it seems like they
killed off the grand Inquisitor I don't
think they ultimately killed off the
granite quiz yeah no uh it seems like
they're playing for season two to be
honest with you which I'm not gonna
complain if we get another season of the
show absolutely not absolutely not I
just think uh um overall I don't want to
take away anyone's enjoyment from it I'm
still really really enjoying the show
overall it's just there's a couple silly
moments in this episode where I was just
like huh what and I loved it where you
ate it I love it I love it I ate it up
hey okay with us and we'll leave it
there for this episode of WikiLeaks and
again my Easter egg breakdown is coming
tomorrow a huge thanks to Jessica
Clements for filling in this episode it
was such a delight chatting this episode
with you
so much fun uh don't forget to check out
our great merch options over at New
rockstarsmerch.com follow me at EA boss
followed Jessica at Lulu underscore
Clemens is that still your Twitter
handle yeah yes it is awesome uh follow
new Rockstar on social media subscribe
to WikiLeaks forever get your podcast
thank you for watching and goodbye
foreign